Now, let's actually try
to quantify all of this.
Imagine I have an input image
which has been defocused, and
what we basically want
to do is now look at.
Remember the, all those defocused
regions that we'd looked at,
basically calibrate these blur
kernels at different depths.
If can calibrate them,
perhaps we can now model the response
on an image because of different types,
you know, different blur
kernels that are coming in.
Because again,
these are response functions we
saw when we moved objects around.
If you actually went through
an exercise of doing that,
what we did of trying to move an object.
We might be able to kind of build
a model that could be used to generate
this information.
So, let's look at this
a little bit more carefully.
So imagine, I could now come up with
some sort of a local sub-window and
also look at how
the calibrated blur kernel for
that image would look
like at certain depth k.
That would actually be fk,
so, I have a window, yk,
I have a new calibrated
blur at different depths k.
And we call that fk.
And basically, now, we can basically
come up with a sharp output x on that
sub window, by doing what we know how
to do which is convolutions, right?
So, it basically means is for
a specific depth,
I can now come up with
different types of images.
So, k1, k2 and k3.
So, I'm just showing you
a simple table here.
This is my image,
I found different sub-windows.
And I can now compute if
I know the blur kernel.
And, these are again, if you noticed
the ones that we had looked at as from
the example of images earlier.
When we basically moved
the lens moved the object,
the light source away from the lens.
We've got different spread
functions out of it.
We can actually use this to now,
of course, compute sharp images.
And of course, no surprise to you how
we do this is a simple convolution
of the calibrated blur kernel.
With the sharp window here to be
able to create a local sub-window.
Right?
So this is how we would actually do it.
This is a forward process,
if I had this,
I would actually be able to compute it.
Of course, my interest is in
actually computing this, right?
I want to be able to actually
come up with a sharps sub-window.
So the inverse of this process
is what we are interested in.
But, we can actually do
calibration this way.